how's Escobar coming through is he gonna
be able to get to that analyst has come
a long way in the last 25 years
countless leagues have come and gone
trying to establish themselves the next
big thing many of them winding up
failing MLS looked like it might be
joining them early years contracting
teams and struggling to get by with the
league persevered and is now thriving as
it enters the 25th season MLS now has
plans to go to 30 teams and as those new
owners come into the league they need to
pay an expansion fee essentially getting
their stake in the league's operations
and their right to operate a team in a
city in 2012 Montreal Impact joined the
league at expansion fee of 40 million
dollars it's a significant increase from
the five million dollars the original
owners are paying in 1995 however it is
nothing compared to owners are paying
today just look at some of the recent
additions teams in New York Minnesota
sold for a hundred million dollars
Cincinnati started playing last year and
Nashville's start in 2020 those teams
both went for one hundred fifty million
dollars planned expansion teams in
Sacramento and st. Louis will be for 200
million and David Tepper whose founding
a team in North Carolina is paying a
reported 325 million dollars just for
the right to separate that team the
competition has been very very healthy
when you think about the number of
cities that have tried to get into this
expansion conversation that healthy
competition helps us as the league make
more informed and better decisions about
who should come next and why expansion
fees are tremendous barometer for the
league's financial success not only do
they reflect the demand that owner is
you know willing to pay hundreds of
millions of dollars to be a part of MLS
they're not even expecting to make a
profit in the near term MLS is still
struggling to get in the black the
league loses money and only seven teams
are profitable so why are these
sophisticated investors willing to lose
all of this money to be part of MLS the
truth is that it's not based in
financials and it's not even based in
MLS these investors want a part of the
American Soccer landscape and MLS is the
way to get there and it's frankly a
speculative bet they're expecting that
they're getting on the ground floor and
as soccer continues to explode in
popularity United States they're going
to be there with a
stake in the game there's been a need to
expand you can argue maybe it's too fast
too soon but at the end of the day the
interest is there we have communities
all over our country that want MLS
franchise if you thought that was going
to be the case 24 years ago wasn't a lot
of indicators are suggesting they've
made a smart bet attendance is way up
from 14,000 fans a game in the early
seasons to well over 20,000 fans a game
now sponsors are buying in the league
has blue chip sponsors as do the team's
target spent nearly three decades as a
Motorsports partner before leaving the
industry entirely just to be a part of
MLS an adidas league's apparel sponsor
spends almost a hundred seventeen
million dollars a year on average which
is more than it pays the NHL it's now a
landing pad for the top coaches and some
of the top players in the world I think
for me the thing that has changed the
most is just the perception of MLS as it
relates to world soccer I think that
it's more respected now than it's ever
been in its entirety of its existence I
think that players young players whether
they're American or foreign to South
America and European doesn't matter I
think that they can come to MLS and know
that there are going to be eyeballs
watching them every single time they
step on the field if you can stay on
this trajectory this guy truly is the
limit for MLS in the next 25 years
you